second I'm glad to be back at an auto
show here in New York with Steve cannon
Steve you guys have been really beefing
up this GL line you have the in Detroit
the G le coop right which was I thought
the best car the show and now you've got
kind of a plug-in hybrid version right
of this talk to me about the plug-in
hybrids because it's doing for consumers
now what it was what's been doing for
high-performance race cars the last
couple of years sure so the G le is our
our largest volume products are most
important SUV comes in the widest
variety of power trains from diesel to
gasoline plug-in hybrid is a real focus
for us so over the next couple years
going to be rolling out 11 of these
eight cylinder power with essentially
four cylinder consumption 20 miles full
electric and meets the 2025 standard
already in 2015 so I mean that's the
main point is I like Mercedes
twin-turbocharged v8 but you get the
same kind of power from a v6 and an
electric engine combined in the
drivetrain so you can be green but you
can also have the kind of power that
someone who doesn't care about the
environment the Sun normally yes so most
people think of hybrid in terms of
consumption and economy but electric
power has has full torque available
available immediately so think of it as
a turbocharger so in that low rev range
it you get the electric and that it then
it kicks in the gasoline and you get a
pretty seamless driving experience all
right talk to me about SUV sales
obviously these are great sellers for
you the ML class as well we just
finished up the month of March how was
it so coming off of biggest march in the
history of the company biggest first
point mystery of the confident history
of mercedes-benz e the u.s. biggest
first quarter twenty nine thousand nine
hundred plus units so just about a
little over nine percent growth we think
sport utilities this is going to be kind
of the year of the sport utility in the
United States with low gas prices and a
strong economy this is the format that
Americans like so advantage goes to the
manufacturer with the product and we've
got five product offerings in the SUV
range
in 2015 20 9900 units nine percent
growth that's breaking news guys you can
flash the red the red banners their best
march ever how much of it was the was
the SUVs and how much of it is the sort
of entry-level segment which has been
such a hot seller with the Millennials
for you guys so we're strong all across
the lineup it's not just the entry
segment so we're seeing strength from
entry products GLA CLA all the way up to
and we're introducing the Maybach this
year and the GTS so it's not just an
entry phenomenon that's fueling our
growth so strong sales this year trucks
will outsell cars probably about fifty
four percent will be the split because
there's just a natural bias for SE of
these in the US market so again the g le
the g le coupe we've got the GLC coming
later in this year the fact that we've
got a whole range of fully refreshed and
brand new products in a year when suvs
are going to be so important we think
gives us a nice advantage and means that
the prospects for full 2015 are really
strong I just I just know that a lot of
kind of Silicon Valley millionaires and
their 20s that by the CLA because they
want a four-cylinder better engine for
the environment but it's kind of still a
hot flashy car what about the
millionaires in their 30s that are
buying GTS is and that are gonna line up
the Maybach I mean how how is the super
luxury range doing for you guys so we're
adding products so the s-class platform
which is done really strong came off of
one of the best s-class years ever last
year the s-class outsold all of its key
competitors combined in 2014 so off to a
great start already this year we're
adding the Maybach which is kind of up
in the 200,000 range to compete with the
Bentleys and the Rolls Royces of the
world adding the GT and the GTS this
year so we're adding as many high-end
products as we are and low end products
and just to dispel kind of the myth that
the only growth in the luxury space is
coming through up from that 35 thousand
dollars CLA GLA price point again strong
growth at the very top which
on balance you know means this is just a
really strong market let me ask about
your competitors the last couple of days
we've seen two American car makers put
out new products or at least a concept
in the case of Lincoln are you are you
worried at all or are you threatened at
all they're going to try and break into
the top to your luxury segment look
they're there they're rolling out very
careful very political about this
they're rolling out great product it's
improving it's a competitive space
everybody wants to be in the luxury
business it's a desirable place it's a
desirable demographic but we're a tough
we're a tough brand abida one of the
most iconic global brands were strong
not just in the United States all over
the world our product offensive we've
got 30 products over the course of six
years one new product every three months
for the next five years which means that
there's always going to be something
fresh and new and interesting to talk to
about at mercedes-benz so while they're
adding one into we're launching five new
products this year so again we ain't
very kind of that you like the
competition Steve cannon being very
polite and kind obviously the stars of
stood guard mercedes-benz not worried
about luxury competitor